spring in the former coach at LSU Les
Miles coach good morning how are you dan
enjoying the day beautiful sunny day
here in Louisiana are you going to you
going to stay in Louisiana no matter
what I think I think if there is
certainly the enjoyable opportunity for
a to be the head football coach at a
call the institution would be out of
state yeah then I think I would have to
move what if you as the rumor was I
don't know if it's a report that you
would work for ESPN is that still
possibility um I think that there's
nothing off the table at this point I
certainly said it's a great career and
great fun and people like yourself in
the media that that you know are
entertaining and enjoy conversation of
sport and I think it's perfect so I
don't I don't think that that that is
off the table but I first and foremost
I'm looking to be a coach it's it's what
I trained to do for a lifetime and
there's too much in me that enjoys
coaching more likely to see on the
sidelines or in the studio 2017 on the
sideline if it's my choice absolutely on
the sidelines do you think it's close
but not in the next week have you had an
offer from any school not not that not
that i would share what i would care to
exchange information on i can tell you
that i've enjoyed the process enjoyed
the people that I've met I feel like
it's a there's people there that I will
be friends with for a long time but I
will not necessarily be coaching at
their school
okay how about this state of the school
that might have been interested in you
yeah they were in one the stasis see I
thought Purdue might be a great
situation for you I think produce a
great school I think there's some you
know the the problem with that is that
you know I I got come from Big Ten
background and it's a you know the last
time that I was there as I recall we
didn't finish like we'd like and
finished second in that game and and
that was the last time that I played
there so i think that was there's some
some some remnants of that old memory
that affected me he's less miles former
LSU head coach joining us if you were
still the head coach and Leonard
fournette came to you and said I'm going
to think about sitting out this bowl
game to get ready for the draft your
reaction would be one yeah i would i
would want to know exactly what's going
on I couldn't I couldn't make a decision
based on those things well if but if
Leonard came and said you know it's it's
I should really not play or if the
doctor who treats when it says you know
he's not he's seventy percent or he's
eighty percent or he's really just not
as good as he should be and you know
maybe it's a wise position to take to
put him on the sideline and to put him
in a position where he knows now and the
team knows now that we're not going to
play but you know certainly if Leonard
was healthy I don't think there would be
any question in this heart that he would
want to play his last college game with
his teammates and this is where the
purple gold and enjoy into 'take in the
field with his lifetime fries so I you
know is this is this is not an easy
position certainly nothing Leonard not
for for Christian McCaffrey those people
you know are advising you know you have
to you have to be careful not to be
injured and there certainly there's
advisors that are saying that well to
some degree there exactly right if that
ankles you know banged up and they'll
have the ability to play as well as
they're capable could not protect
themselves than they need to be removed
but if if they add the player says no
I'm good I'm ready to play then you know
what what happens is the NFL they get a
grade on a player and they in the study
the film and what they study is this the
last game the first game the most rival
games in the season and they bring those
to the front and they they break that
they break down the the evals and so the
opportunity for if you're not injured
that if this is a a game where you're
playing for a bowl championship you can
you can improve your draft position by
making the opinion that you know like
person's jeremyhill played so well
against Iowa I'm absolutely certain he
improved his pole position and left
early thereafter but well you're not
healthy in your pudding injury at risk
then you need to remove yourself and I
don't know exactly where Leonard is and
certainly I don't know Christian
McCaffrey is either would it be a knock
do you think for you know- for a head
coach in the NFL to look at a player
like McCaffrey or for net who did not
play in their final game did not play in
a bowl game well I don't think that they
would have the opportunity to look at
him in a negative way considering that
they BFF alice is a number of guys that
are making you know business decisions
you know it was their play as well I
think that the I think be the NFL coach
wants guys that want to play for the
team and want to create relationships on
that team and I think that both guys
will have that abilities do that and I
think that they look at
the the draft stock in the impending you
know well that could come it's a pretty
unique situation and not they and not
one that would you know affect a
decision not to play adversely in other
words if I'm an NFL NFL coach and I know
that this guy's put himself in the best
position he can to be drafted then I'm
going to respect that I'm going to
unless I'm gonna see the lake my own
opinion about how good he is or isn't
and i'ma grafting without regard to the
last game now the the Great America that
watches college football the the less
miles doesn't stand doesnt sit who
stands with his family and watches games
and calls plays and has a blast they
want to see McCaffrey and they want to
see fun that and and they want to see
the best team at Stanford has in the
best team that LSU has and but they
don't get a boat and because it's really
just more important that the player
respect the fact that he's going to be
drafted for the first time and that he
needs to be healthy to do so did for
nettalk it all to you starting this year
of sitting out this year there was talk
of coming off that great sophomore year
of why would he risk injury was there
any consideration to him not playing
this past season I none that he voiced
to me he I can't imagine that he didn't
want to set more rushing records at LSU
I can't imagine that he didn't have
things to to get accomplished and I
don't I don't think there's any any
fought to him that he would be sitting
out as the season unfolded if coach
Peterson in Washington ask you how to
beat Alabama what would you tell him I
tell them ma you best be able to handle
the front three big defensive tackles
defensive end styles that will that will
knock you back and because nasara starts
from there and the running game is
really this is halted by those big
strong men up front and and if you make
it a one-dimensional game if in fact
it's going to be a Washington has to
step back and fill the football mmm
because because that meant pass rush is
going to come so they had best be able
to move the football on the ground in
intermediate throws they need to make
sure that they're not holding the ball a
long time and we work hard for 1st
pounds if you work hard for first downs
you can you can you can see on the field
with a very quality Alabama team the you
know in stopping them I think that their
offense is a very good one very talented
one but I think there I think were there
specialists on the defensive side of the
ball and really special teams so I would
I would make sure that i built a package
that could keep the ball in my defense
could rest and then I would want to make
sure that my special teams because the
last time that we played those guys so
they always seem to get us in special
team situations so but I'd say it's
going to be a heck of a game and I look
forward to watching it and tell you that
well great too great to catch up with
you good luck whatever you decide to do
whether it's broadcasting for a little
while and then coaching after that but
thanks for joining us coach Dan my
pleasure that's less miles former LSU
head coach the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
you